All right! Mor Chen,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
I’m very happy to be here.
Really great to have you.
So, you’re calling from Israel,
from Tel-Aviv?
Yeah, true. It’s Shavuot here.
Yeah! Happy holidays!
Yeah. So, going to
eat a lot tonight.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
Yeah. I’m very jealous.
My family is having a
wonderful dinner right now.
And hopefully,
next year this time,
I can be with them.
But with COVID,
we’re learning
that everything is virtual.
So, trying to also embrace that.
Yeah. I’m sure you
did the Passover
also via Zoom together
with all the family.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
Really unique.
So, Mor, it’s such a unique
privilege to speak with you.
I went through 8200 for 5 years.
You’re running EISP,
which you’ll tell me what
it’s about in a second.
But it’s very,
very relevant to 8200.
But you also have
a very technical background
yourself as software engineer
from VMware.
And I’m fascinated
to hear about your intersection
between running an incredible
community and accelerators,
such as EISP, while also being
technical yourself,
and how does this all
relate to also women in tech,
which is also something
you’re very passionate about.
Let’s just get started.
What is EISP?
Yeah, perfect.
So, we're starting from the end,
actually, but we’ll get to the
beginning probably again.
So, the EISP is a startup
accelerator in Israel.
It was founded
by the 8200 Alumni Association
10 years ago when actually
the ecosystem in Israel --
it was already a good ecosystem
but there were not so many
formal programs for entrepreneurs
in their early stages.
So, it was one of the first.
And it is one of the leading
ones in Israel today.
Yeah.
So, we -- early staged
entrepreneurs helping them
build and grow their ventures.
And we have some
great companies in our portfolio.
So, why is 8200 a part of it,
because my understanding
is that it’s not exclusively
for the 8200.
And for anybody
who doesn’t know 8200,
it’s the cyber security considered
like the elite unit of the army
for the computer nerds like we are.
True. So, I think like
when the Alumni Association
started to think about activities
and what they can do
in the Israeli society
and help Israel society --
so you said it's
a very elite tech unit.
But then, when you
look at the industry,
a lot of the startups
that were founded in --
and the good ones in Israel
were founded by 8200 Alumni.
So, it was very natural to think
about the entrepreneurship
and the innovation ecosystems,
and see how we can
contribute there.
And then, at first,
they thought about,
okay, so within the 8200 unit,
you get great skillset.
You get great experience
and you get a great network,
which helps you along the way
throughout your career.
And also, once we get to it,
you will see how it also
help mine.
But the other people who are not
necessarily serving in these units,
Yeah.
they do not benefit
from the same --
being part of this community.
So, the logic was let’s do
the other way around.
So usually, alumni association,
they work for their own alumni.
And the 8200 Alumni Association
decided to work for Israel
community and society
as a whole and taking this closed
network of 8200 alumni
and open it to any
Israeli entrepreneur.
And this is kind of the DNA
of the program
and the alumni association itself.
Very nice. Okay.
So now, how are you
related to that --?
And you mentioned that it also
very much impacted your own
upbringing into the tech world.
True. So, I think that ever since
I was very, very young,
I was always very
passionate about tech.
And I always thought that
I would like to pursue
a career in tech.
So, obviously I know that
you’re also an 8200 alumni,
so you know.
So, when I was like 16,
I started the process
to get in track
in today’s Israeli defense forces.
And after passing so many
interviews and exams,
I was accepted to the 8200 unit.
I did the intelligence
force there,
which really opened
my mind to the wonderful things
you can do with technology.
After the army, I studied also
Computer Science and Statistics.
So, I wanted to get more
the theoretical
understanding of how things --
how to think correctly about
solving problems in general,
but also specifically
like tech problems.
And then, I was working for
a while as a software engineer.
I think that along the way,
I understood that
a lot of the skillset
that I gained from being
a software engineer could also
benefit in other roles
and other industries.
And then, I wanted
to tap into the more --
- the business –
- A little bit about that
though, Mor.
I had to stop you.
Yeah, that’s fine, actually.
This idea --
because I agree completely.
This idea that the skillsets
you’re getting as a software
engineer are indirectly
very relevant to
a lot of other industries.
What’s your take on that?
So, I absolutely agree.
And along the way,
and throughout my career,
I think time and time again,
I see that this is true.
So, basically everyone thinks
that being a software engineer
is like programming.
But it’s more than that.
It starts with getting
a vague problem.
You have to do something
that you don’t necessarily know
how to approach to or what to do,
and then doing it
very efficiently
and doing it --
So, you have a vague problem.
You have to break it
into little components.
Think about each of them.
Do a lot of iterations.
Make it better.
Make it more efficient.
And then, I think once you have
that logical and very structured
way of thinking about
problems in general
and approaching challenges,
if you know how to also
implement that in other
industries and in other roles,
so this really help.
So, after working
as a software engineer,
I went to strategy consulting,
which is almost 180.
And there, I really saw it
because you’re coming...
You're coming
for a very short while.
You’re joining a company
for like three months
and you have like an enormous
scope of work.
Your work is like
you have to basically
come up with a new strategy
to a company who is working
for 30 years.
Everything is great.
They are growing,
but now, something
is missing or there --
they want to be better.
And then, you have to understand
how to break it and understand
where are the --
what are the main issues,
what hypothesis you can make.
Challenge all kinds of
assumptions that they have.
And this way of thinking
really helped me also
as a strategy consultant.
I mean, this whole idea,
this magnificent idea
that you’re taking a huge,
huge problem, anything in life --
it can be an algorithm,
but it can be a leadership
position or strategy.
And this methodology
of breaking it down,
of divide them and conquer,
and then piecing them together
back to understand
everything is manageable.
It’s only a mindset of how
efficient they are able to
divide it, and then conquer it.
I think that’s just phenomenal.
So, you went to strategy.
You did those consulting,
which I think is --
That’s definitely something that
I look forward to experiencing
one day as well because
you’re coming in,
you’re getting these really
interesting insights.
And then, you go into
the accelerator phase
or the community phase, right?
So -- yeah...
So, this is almost the story.
This is very --
So, I always knew that
in some point,
I would like to take
the experience that I’ve gained
as a business and strategy
consultant and go back into
the tech world because
this was my starting position.
This is really who I am,
basically.
And then, I didn’t know
how it will connect,
but I knew it will connect
at some point.
I actually planned to go
and pursue an MBA.
- Really?
- But then -- Yeah.
But then, I met Sharin,
which you know very well.
She was the previous
managing director.
My ancestor, let’s say.
[laughs]
And she --
We met.
And then, she offered --
like a few months after we met,
she offered me this role,
which totally changed everything
for me because
I was really on a --
like, I already had
my application written.
[unclear] did everything
and it was like around August,
which is very close
to the deadlines.
And then,
it took me like a few --
I think like 48 hours to think
about that and I felt that this is
exactly the opportunity
that I’ve been waiting for
in that time in my career,
to take a tech experience
together with my
consultant experience,
combining them to assist
the early-stage entrepreneurs.
And I’m very happy that I did that.
So, Mor, how many entrepreneurs
did you get to work with
personally throughout
your time at EISP?
So, the ones that were part
of like the cohort that I led,
around let’s say, 30.
But then, obviously, we support
our alumni community,
which is like 120 startups
in different stages,
different verticals, which is
a whole different challenge.
And then, on my spare time,
if I have that,
I like helping other entrepreneurs
who did not --
who were not accepted
to our program.
I think it’s very important
to give them the proper feedback
and try to help if you have
the network and the experience.
Try to help wherever you can.
Amazing! No, I actually have
two great friends
who did the program recently,
Tomer Zuaretz and Imri Hecht.
Oh, I love him. Wow. Oh, man.
He actually sat next to me in the
army for about a year and a half.
We were on the same team.
Incredible. Incredible people.
And they just mentioned
how incredible the program is.
So, what are sort of the values
that you bring into the program?
When you look at an accelerator
and you look at the 150
entrepreneurs that have
gone through this program,
what makes it unique
versus any other accelerator
that just aims to kickstart
the progress of these
early-stage startups?
Yeah. So, I think, first of all,
is the reputation that we have.
- Yeah.
- And the --
We’ve been operating
for 10 years.
There are, I think, very little
like other startups --
not a lot of startups
in the Israeli ecosystem
that have been operating
for that long.
And this means that
we have a lot of experience.
- So --
- Yeah.
from cycle to cycle, year to year,
managing director to other,
we really --
We evolve. We learn.
We’re getting better.
So, I think today, if you ask –
More than that, Mor,
I think you actually have
the opportunity --
unlike other accelerators,
you see the whole life cycle
from inception to,
potentially,
exit because the average
life cycle of a startup
is seven to nine years.
So, you actually get to
now debrief over your initial
cohorts and see, "Okay,
what happened over these
seven to nine years?"
True. So, we have the data
and we’re following the data.
And we’re seeing like --
Wonderful.
We’re trying to learn from that,
which companies
we can help and which
companies we --
We did the right --
We selected them properly.
And we have some
companies who already --
as you said, they already exited.
And I think --
So, first is the experience,
your reputation.
Second, it’s the network.
So, we’re not only
approaching 8200 alumni,
but the background
is 8200 alumni.
And within that network
in Israel and also
in Silicon Valley, San Francisco,
and all around the world,
there is a strong community
which is very united.
I’m sure you’re taking part
in the activity of the community.
- Definitely.
- Yeah. So, we --
we really --
they’re really up for
the challenge
to assist entrepreneurs.
And whenever I approach someone
from the network, they’re always,
always happy to assist----
opening doors, giving consultation, mentoring the startups,
which is a really great network
to have for entrepreneurs.
We’re a non-profit organization,
which is different
from other startups.
It’s very different from
other accelerators, right?
It’s very uncommon.
True. Every year,
we think about that,
whether we want to raise a fund
and start investing
or we want to be --
we want to stay a non-profit.
So, we do not take equity.
We do not invest, which is nice.
But I think that, more than that,
it means that we are --
we don’t have a specific agenda.
We really want to do
what’s best for the company.
I think that if you’re backed by
a specific VC
or backed by a corporate,
so obviously, you want to
promote their agenda
or their specific requirements.
And here,
really, if an entrepreneur
wants to raise money,
he doesn’t have any obligation.
I will introduce him to all
the VCs that are relevant to him
and all the investors.
And if he’s not committed
to any specific VC,
which I think is really great --
and if –
In Israel, as you know,
now with the situation,
everything shifts a bit.
But money is not an issue
if you’re a good entrepreneur.
It’s just come to the investors
at the right timing.
And sometimes,
if you go to an accelerator,
it means that you
still need to be --
you need to be --
to do some polishing.
But you have amazing raw material.
And then, if you go to investors,
then you would probably won’t
get the best deal.
So, I think that getting money
from accelerators is
not necessarily the best thing
for the company.
Yeah. Well, my que --
So, I’m going to challenge
you on that because I’m wondering –
Go ahead.
Do you think that there are some
startups that might be hesitant
to join or to apply to 8200,
to this accelerator because of
the fact that you’re
not taking equity?
Because they might feel that if
you don’t have a stake
in their company, then maybe
you’re not going to give them
as much attention
as other accelerators,
or that you’re not going to be
as advocative in helping
connect them?
Or is that not even
a worry for startups, because a --
because this accelerator
is one of the best well-known
accelerators in the country?
Yeah. So, that’s
a good question, actually.
We always ask
the other way around.
We always think that --
So, you’re asking if --
because we’re not putting money
or taking any equity,
so we will not invest --
we will not do
our best to help them –
Maybe [inaudible] both.
I don’t know.
Yeah.
I’m not sure if that’s a concern.
I never heard an entrepreneur
who is worried about
the program because of that.
And this leads me to the already
good results that we
have talking to --
even if you talk to Tomer,
I’m sure he will be
able to tell you --
And he was one of our --
He’s amazing.
I’m sure he would have succeeded
without our help.
But being able to introduce him
to so many investors and also
potential customers was really --
I’m sure it really helped him.
But I don’t think --
I think if they do have any --
if entrepreneurs
have this concern,
they talk to me.
I’m very, very approachable.
I love talking to entrepreneurs
or other alumni in our portfolio.
And then, I’m sure they won’t
be worried about that.
Oh, I love it.
At the end, it’s all about
what’s actually happening
on the field and I’m seeing
all these incredible things that
you’re doing for the startups.
I’m observing in social media.
And I’m talking to Tomer
and Imri, and all my friends
who are doing it and it’s li --
it is one of the best run
accelerators that I’ve seen.
There are so many accelerators
that people come out and
they tell me,
“Michael, we did this.
"We actually quit
accelerators."
"We feel like,
'Ah, it was worth it,'
and 'not so worth it.'”
I only heard rave reviews about
what you’re doing there.
We just have a few minutes,
and I thought this was a shame.
But I’d love to get a little bit
about your passion
for women in tech.
And then, I’m going to --
and then, we’ll shift it to a few
more things that I have in mind.
Ah, so let’s go.
Let’s try to do it quick.
20 minutes goes by
really fast when you enjoy –
- Time flies. It’s unbelievable.
- Yeah. [laughs]
So, women in tech.
So, one of my personal passion
is about that. So I'm a woman,
I'm coming from tech.
I know how --
most of my time,
I was one of the few
during university.
Then looking at the industry,
there are only around 3% in Israel,
3% female entrepreneurs.
This is something that
I care deeply about.
And I think starting
with education,
where I believe you need
to start there;
so teaching young girls,
opening their minds
- to this kind of field.
- How young do they start?
At what age do you think is
important to really get in there?
From like age zero almost.
Yeah, so all the way
from the beginning.
- into this -- it's -- okay.
- Yeah.
Like exposing them to things
that are more mechanical,
scientific.
And then, also obviously,
encourage them to explore these
ideas as parents and as educator.
I’m actually asking that
because I read recently,
a very interesting study that
showed that actually up until
a certain age, girls outperform
boys in STEM.
But I think at around fifth
or sixth grade,
there are these social norms
that are starting to
divide the groups.
And a lot of scientists are
saying that if we can dive into
that key moment in the
middle school when
they have these cliques,
maybe that will help
change the situation.
I’ll send it to you later.
I thought it was very interesting.
Oh, I’d love to read that.
So, it’s very complex, obviously,
because also, as you said,
there is this social environment.
At the age of 10 or 11,
if you’re not with other girls,
you might feel a bit different
or strange.
But then, obviously,
I think you should start
from the beginning.
My father is very feminist.
He was always like that,
which really helped me
I think from a very young age
to understand that there is --
I can do anything, basically.
I just need to understand what
I want to do
and where is my passion.
But I think that starting
with the parents,
this is the point where you
should start encouraging girls
explore these areas.
I love it, Mor. Last question.
Well, actually, I lied,
I have two more questions.
But for now, where do you see
yourself in like 10, 15 years?
Curiosity -- I mean,
are you doing a startup?
Are you going into --
working for a big company?
Where’s your passion?
Wow! Wish I was brave enough
to start a startup.
It’s so crazy.
I really admire entrepreneurs.
No, no, no, after each --
after you’re seeing all these
people go through it?
So, I do, but I think I like
being an entrepreneur
and being a --
like taking initiatives within
a more structured environment.
So, this is where --
like at the moment,
this is where I feel more --
like, this is where
I feel comfortable.
So, definitely continue
to work with entrepreneurs.
I’m not sure how exactly,
but definitely I’m super --
I love working
with entrepreneurs,
like seeing them,
how they are passionate about
what they’re doing,
trying to change the world
and how I can assist doing that
definitely fulfills
a lot of the things
that I’m looking for in a career.
I love it, Mor.
- Now the last question, finally.
- Yeah. [laughs]
I need three words
that best describe you
or that any of your startups
would describe you as.
[laughs]
I’m sure these
would be different, three words.
So, I think I’m very --
I’m ambitious.
I have very high
emotional intelligence.
And I think that I’m very Israeli
- in every sense of the word.
- Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, yeah, really.
[laughs]
Mor, this is --
I’ve done it
with quite a few Israelis.
This is the first time
I’m hearing that as a word.
I just love it. Toda raba.
Thank you so much.
Toda. I really enjoyed
getting to know you.
Really enjoyed.
- Thank you.
- Take care.